wow
another round of monsoon storms swept
through the las vegas valley overnight
and you can see this video sent to us
from tiana jones winds gusts just
wouldn't let up during the storm
thanks for sending this in tiana and
thank you for joining us at noon i'm
bianca holman there's no doubt that we
need the rain but this monsoon season
has left a mess
downed trees flooding in some
neighborhoods crews busy cleaning it up
hector mejia live at the arroyo grand
sports complex with a look at what
they're dealing with right now
hector hey there well the rain from last
night certainly did not make things any
better for the sports complex still
fixing damage from last week's storms
take a look at the bmx park here
looks like seems to be easily several
inches of standing flood water there and
just along this trail here just off the
side
we have a wash there with water
collected overnight from last night's
rain
moving its way down through here also
here in henderson check out this
uprooted tree
that ended up just inches on top of an
suv overnight
this picture was taken by ryan's tree
care down in south henderson
i'm told tree removal companies are
slammed right now assessing damage not
just from last night but also from last
week
these thunderstorms came with another
punch for homeowners left to pick up
shredded tree limbs
down trees we talked with one henderson
family that's just out here making the
best out of it
here at the arroyo grande sports complex
it was kind of scary this time our power
flickered a lot and i thought oh gosh if
our electricity goes out that's going to
be terrible because the heat
we're picking up to ash with my
granddaughter having a good time she
likes to collect the branches and so
there's a few things down here and there
my dad is awesome with keeping our yard
up and trying to clean up stuff and pick
up pieces and our pool is just trash so
a lot to clean up and check out this
flooding also from last night look at
that
this was shot by our photographer tim
zetlow near racetrack in newport that's
in the southeast henderson area
and back out here at the sports complex
as we were driving in we noticed crews
still fixing the scoreboard that fell
and broke during last week's storm still
so still
it will take a few days for all this to
get cleaned up reporting
at the arroyo granny sports complex
hector mejia 8 news now
all right thanks hector we'll take a
look at the damage in nye county these
are photos posted to the twitter
of the page of the nye county sheriff's
department heavy winds
up to 70 miles per hour caused several
trees to fall in roadways
houses and cars wind also damaged the
roof of
this home and in prump we've got
pictures posted from the town of parum's
twitter page
high winds caused roof damages there
large trees uprooted
falling on roadways and houses as well